foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's
[__] Friday yep finally finally get
ready to go to the club yeah well you
know in about an hour and an hour and a
half or something yeah technically two
hours we're not leaving for two hours
because it doesn't open till 10 I don't
think
so it is it's tonight right momentous
tonight I'm pretty sure like 99 sure
Sebastian says Tom and Jenny the news is
uh is that the keep is to be remade oh
okay oh that I would actually be
interested to see that I wonder if
they're going to make it closer to the
novel
I mean because I haven't seen the movie
in a long time but I just read the novel
like a little while ago
depending on who's doing it there's a
lot of potential for them to [__] that
one up
yeah but there's a potential for it to
be good too because it's a good book
and I kind of feel like
if they're gonna make it nowadays I feel
like they would probably make it closer
to the source material which I think
would be good
you know I don't know the source
material because the book was good I
have it just it's right over there yeah
and I just read it not too long ago it's
got to be a period piece it has to be
back in World War II well yeah I mean
it's gonna suck that's uh you know
they'll might shoot they might cheap out
and try to put that in the modern times
you know you know that would just be
that's the thing it's like if I mean
something like that story that's so
ingrained in the time period that it's
made in it's like if you're gonna just
make it in the modern day like make a
different movie there's really not any
point in making it if it's not gonna be
at the time because it's so much to do
with the story there's so much [__] that
they're doing right now that there's no
point in what they're doing they're just
I don't trust them until I see the
product now one thing we did see uh last
night is uh saw Black Adam I liked it I
liked Black Adam I fell asleep but not
well not not because the movie was bad
but because I was like so so sleepy yeah
it's like I was watching so it's like I
woke up and it was over and I was like
oh yeah she fell asleep at the very end
what happened
it was a good movie though
um um
and uh
the new Shazam is going to come out too
in a couple weeks next yeah next Friday
the new Shazam is out yeah because I
told you I was like I'm pretty sure I'd
been seeing ads and stuff for it so I
was like I know it seemed and he looked
it up and yeah it's next Friday which
next Friday is also St Patrick's Day
yeah it wasn't perfect but it was good I
liked it I thought it was real good I
thought the rock just knocked it out of
the [__] Park I thought he was a
great superhero he's like a dark
superhero almost a villain he's like
he's not like Superman but he's killing
people he's an ancient demigod from some
fictional Middle Eastern
civilization that's long gone it was you
know it died out like 6 000 years ago
but the country's still around it's kind
of like
Babylon is what they're talking about
Babylon
they're in the fictionalized Iraq
and uh
they wake him up using a
some magic words you know Shazam I think
is how they woke him up on it no she
said something what'd she say she said
something kind of specifically yeah like
a whole poem thing he comes out and he
[__] up a bunch of dudes [__] a bunch
of mercenaries
does all kinds of cool [__] and then
some superheroes trying to defend World
Order try to stop him and he's like this
is my country you don't belong here all
your International Peace [__] and
you know and that that was pretty cool
um Pierce Brosnan was in it Pierce Bros
I liked his character actually kind of
played kind of Dr Fate yeah he was kind
of like Doctor Strange similar yeah they
always I mean you know it's like they
see yeah so it's kind of like everything
is sort of like a little ripoff although
I don't know if like DC or Marvel did
that stuff first because I'm not yeah
I'm not well I'm not a super up on the
comic book Laura I'm sure somebody could
tell me it doesn't matter I just like
this no it doesn't matter
if it's a good story and the movie has a
good tone to it I love the tone to
Shazam because it was semi-comedy and I
I like that that's
and it had some good Adventure [__]
happening in it it's kind of I just like
Shazam I like this one I think
just as just as good just as well it is
a different story it had a different
tone
and then in the end
they had a [__] surprise visit man
the international Justice League or
whatever it is I don't remember what
they're called probably his Justice
League
the woman that was running it contacted
him
contacted Black Adam this after he named
himself Black Adam he wasn't called that
before what was he called it was it was
a uh teth Adam it was like like an
Egyptian sounded name
and um
she's like look you can't you know
you're in prisons there in your country
you can't leave and he's like I do what
I want you know nobody on this Earth can
stop me I do what I want yeah I do what
I want that's what I would have said I
said look I do what I want right anyway
so they uh she goes well nobody on this
Earth can stop you but I got a line on
people not from this Earth and [__]
boom Superman shows up and he goes we
need to talk
we see that with that kind of dynamic
was happening in the animated
uh movies for Black Adam and Shazam
Superman would show up you know which I
haven't seen him but Superman shows up
yeah Superman's got to show up you know
what I mean because those dudes are too
too powerful just not to have Superman
show up to keep him under control
yeah I'm a big Superman fan if he's done
right you know y'all like Chris Reeves
stuff I even like that last
[__] dumbass one with the damn
nuclear bad guy I don't even like that
one
the fourth one yeah the fourth one I
liked it it was better than the third
one nuclear man nuclear man yeah I was
gonna say probably Justice For Peace or
world peace or what was the name of that
one was it
the Quest for people Quest for Peace
yeah I was gonna say I think my favorite
thing about
Black Adam was I like that it was like
it had humor in it but it was like a
slightly more serious story in that like
a lot more people got killed but I
thought it was funny how um they added a
lot of levity to him just like throwing
people around and just like he's just
like picking up bad guys
[Laughter]
yeah he's a [__] Mesopotamian God
he's gonna do what he wants you know
what I mean he's super funny every time
it happened I cracked up yeah
like you can't do that that's that's
against the law you know I'm thinking
wait a minute hold on this dude is a
demigod all right and he's in his own
kingdom he is the law you do whatever he
[__] wants he likes he's flying and
he's like taking dudes up and he's like
you can't drop those dudes and he's like
yeah
but uh the rock man [__] Dwayne
Johnson
he was looking juicy as [__] man I mean
he was Juiced up he looked [__] great
Tom is gay for the right I was gay for
his gay for [__]
how much is that his actual physique and
how much is that his suit man he looked
[__] amazing that's just an amazing
man his head is [__] he's just got
this [__] great head make all bald
[__] proud his head
yeah man we're gonna have to save that
for me
that's like a pro that's like the
example to expire to Aspire to is that
if I can Maori head that he's got he
says he he [__] look great man you
look great and he did a good performance
he was good he was good at that
character yeah he was got well I like it
because he was kind of like a morally
gray character you know what I mean he
wasn't a straight up villain but he
wasn't a hero either I mean God would be
red and I kind of liked that like I said
and it was funny the way he just like
flung dudes around and killed him and
he's like what do you mean I can't kill
him
I mean you know no one cared they were
[__] he's like a dark Superman yeah
very dark Superman but he wasn't a bad
guy per se he was just he did some bad
in the past but he caught up
changed his ways bad [__] happened to
him too because he started off as a
mortal
you know he was made into that it's a
good story
Zach says I think he's going to be in
Shazam probably probably Zach says the
director of Shazam has a YouTube channel
where he posts filmmaking tutorials he's
an awesome dude it also helps he's a
handsome as [__] Swedish dude yeah
yeah I couldn't remember his name I know
he reviewed Shazam
because I think we saw it a couple of
times it was good writing
I was good writing
um
it was a good mixture of action
adventure some comedy
uh it had uh
almost some horror aspects because they
open up the gates to hell and a damn
demon comes out yeah the demons were
cool looking yeah they're pretty good
and then the dead started to rise it was
like something out of dab Revelations
and [__] because this is It's Middle
Eastern tone to it so it's going to have
Middle Eastern style religious motifs in
it it was good see I missed the last
part so I'm gonna have to like go back
and watch it's on HBO Max that's where
we saw because I was just like scrolling
through looking for something fun to
watch and like I just saw it on there
and I knew he wanted to see it so once
that guy
died and went to hell the Satan
promoted him to like [__] a champion
archdemon and sent him back
to Earth
to capture what was the name of the
country
I think it was I think uh now I can't
remember
kunda something or other no it didn't
matter it's just a fictional man it was
a fictional Middle Eastern country
but he comes back in the the Evil Dead
started to rise up out of the ground
people had to fight him
I hate when that happens
it's like the skeletons out of Jason the
Argonauts it's kind of like that they
were CG
Zach said I've been doing a fan edit of
Quantum of Solace
because my God is the actual dating in
that movie painful so much of it is just
slowing down reaction shots because that
movie lets nothing lets nothing breathe
yeah I mean I liked Quantum of Solace
better the second and third time I saw
it but like the first time I saw it it
was like my least favorite of all the um
Daniel Craig
uh 007s but I like it better now that
I've seen it a couple of times but it's
still like my least favorite probably
out of the four or five
of them out of the five uh I'm just I
just got to disagree I liked Quantum of
Salas I did when I first saw it I did I
didn't like it as much as um of uh as
Casino Royale but the more I watched it
the more I liked it it had a lot of
hidden messages the cult messages in it
I liked and it um
it's had a bunch of alchemy imagery in
it
which I haven't totally feel that
burning water over oil and and
it's pretty cool
um
it just was the the thing the thing that
really didn't gel with that is
they showed Specter but they didn't call
it Specter he didn't know what it was
you could tell that they had that they
weren't working from a script
that was overarching into multiple
movies they were just kinda
making stuff up as they were going along
about the world the universe not the
story but the James Bond universe that
they were in you could tell they didn't
quite know what they which direction the
movies were going to go
because Judy Dench is like there's
something out there we don't know what
it is but something's attacking us it's
infiltrated us
and uh and then he sees him at the Opera
and he takes a radio and he can hear
them all talking and then he talks to
him there were a bunch of oligarchs in
the in the Opera talking and they were
there was some kind of a modernistic
rendition of some Opera and I'd like to
find out what song that was
and what Opera that was it was probably
pertinent to the story
I feel like
I feel like I knew what Opera it was and
now I can't remember so a bunch of
people in robes and there was an
All-Seeing Eye in the background yeah
singing um I was like that means
something that has something to expect
her God damn it
so some kind of world government thing
somebody will probably like say but I I
feel like because remember we did a
video a long time ago
where we talked about the Daniel Craig
uh James Bond movies and I'm pretty sure
that I came across what Opera that was
during that because I feel like that's a
piece of information that I knew yeah
I didn't know it was Tosca says yeah
which is actually quite a famous and
Opera that particular act what was
happening in I don't know I don't really
know I'm not super familiar with the
Flop with the plot okay
um grandfather's says final episode of
The Last of Us is on Sunday yeah I
really need to get into that everybody
and their mom has recommended that to me
so
I'll get around to it eventually maybe
like 10 years from now because there's
still like a bunch of [__]
it's like razor says uh Last of Us ranks
up there with HBO's best Chernobyl
dewire Sopranos
um yeah I haven't even seen The Sopranos
yet so
I'm like way way way behind I just feel
like I'm never gonna have time like it's
I think I've said this before but I feel
like I'm never gonna have time to like
watch all the good [__] all the good
[__] you know what I mean because I'm so
behind on stuff
and I don't I don't know when I'm ever
gonna have time to watch it all there's
just so much good stuff you know
and so many books and stuff I gotta read
still John Smith says that Roger Moore
was the James Bond for him
um
I didn't really like I mean I went up
growing up as a kid I watched that and I
enjoyed them in those days
but but I'd go back and look at some of
that stuff I haven't watched all of his
movies of course in a long time but I I
have I saw a Moonraker it was actually
pretty good
I remember Moonraker being like one of
the worst ones yeah I remember everybody
complaining about how sucky Moonraker
was but it's like I haven't seen it
since I was a kid I went back and saw it
and I thought it was pretty cool
um the thing was about it is that I just
really can't buy that I can't really buy
the [__] Roger War would shoot you he
doesn't come across as a date as a
dangerous dude he comes across as a
[__] tall skinny model
when it comes to the Retro James Bonds I
like Timothy Dalton in the first movie
review to a Kill it was a lot like so it
was a lot like Christina Royale that
tone
and if you do a kill nothing to kill
what was uh Living Daylights yeah I was
gonna say yeah yeah
uh Living Daylights was uh
was great it was like one of the newer
ones it had everything of James Bond
movies should have you know Russian
assassin Spy Girls
that turn out to be good instead of bad
they were kind of and then uh Pipelines
they were trying to go from one country
to the next through a damn oil pipeline
there's all kinds of good Chase scenes
and like stuff out of Mad Max car chase
scenes and car wrecks
it was it was just it had all the
elements of a good James Bond movie and
it was gritty for the time it wouldn't
be gritty by today's standards but it
was gritty yeah compared to we're at
Peak grittiness now yeah it was gritty
compared to
Roger Moore James Bond
and then I watched this the one that
came out after that that had Dalton in
it and it it went back to Roger Moore
kind of silliness
it had some good stuff in it
but it had too much humor in it I think
it was
humor and some corniness to it that I
didn't like
well I guess the nice thing about it is
that there have been so many James Bonds
and everybody had their own take on the
character that you can kind of like
watch whatever kind you're in the mood
for you know yeah like everybody's gonna
have a lot of them like because John
Smith said I liked my bond silly but
facing off against Christopher Lee and
the Man with the Golden Gun is awesome
uh grandther says Roger Moore's fight
scenes were like watching an adolescent
karate class yeah yeah
just a joke Zach says uh Roger Moore
always makes me think of like your best
friend in high school's cool Dad instead
of a spy yeah
and you know where uh Timothy Dalton
grabs some woman he's in a hotel if I
remember correctly and he grabs her and
puts a gut in the back of her head kind
of uses her as a human shield threatens
to kill her she moves I think I don't
remember what if he broke into her
apartment trying to find something or
broke into her hotel
but that was the first time you saw a
bond point of God at a woman a
threatened to kill her and you kind of
buy that he would do it yeah and
that kind of fits more what the novels
were like you know
really out of all of all of them you
know the
Daniel Craig would be closest
to the way he was in the novels [__]
up
kind of a thug not not good looking but
kind of handsome because she's just beat
up looking look like a boxer
the only difference is that in the book
he had dark hair
it wasn't blonde
but you know that worked
yeah I mean I I think he definitely made
a really good yeah that's that's what
the books were taught that's what Ian
Fleming was talking about pretty much
because to be honest it's like when I
was a kid I somehow managed to see
pretty much all the James Bond movies at
one point or another because it may be
because they were always on you know
like on cable or something and I was
never super super into them but I always
kind of like watched them when they were
on but I don't think I really got into
like the James Bond movies until the
Daniel Craig movies yeah you know what I
mean even though I'd seen all of them
like when I was growing up
well when I was growing up he was kind
of like just a British superhero he
wasn't a realistic character
it was like a superhero well especially
when Roger Moore was doing yeah because
it's like hey look I have a wet I have a
I have a tuxedo on under my wetsuit yeah
yeah
right and he's like and then he just
like goes in a casino and everyone's not
like going what the [__]
and he's [__] in his 60s
and he's not jacked or anything but for
some strange reason all these 22 year
old women are just draped and just
[__] falling all over him you know it
doesn't happen in real life unless you
got a [__] ton of money and these are
hookers you know that's the one yeah
maybe there's a suckers they're just
hookers that would be that would be
that'd be the only explanation yeah it's
like what yeah it's like does he have
some kind of pheromones on him or
something like that it's like what is
going on yeah grams just said watching a
60 year old more bed a 25 year old yeah
yeah it just seems a bit icky yeah it is
it is quite icky I mean it's like hey
it's like I'm sleeping with my
granddaughter yeah
not not a good look if it's technically
it's legal but it's still kind of yucky
yeah it didn't look good on camera with
him because he was just skinny you know
he definitely looked his age
yeah he just looked his eight I mean
I mean uh Daniel Craig
was with a younger woman but it looked
like he could get that woman
yeah it didn't seem like I mean I don't
know
um because you know in the newer ones I
don't know the age difference between
she was about 30. Daniel Craig and the
and the actress playing like the women
in the movies but it didn't look like as
big a difference no she was about 30. he
was probably in his mid 50s
yeah it just didn't look like I mean in
the Roger Moore ones I mean you could
clearly tell he was like an old man yeah
and they were like very very young you
could tell they were paid to be there
well yeah
oh
see Skyfall probably had the best
villain with Javier Bardem yeah I mean I
love Javier it did but what was funny
about that that episode or that movie
is that it that Specter didn't seem to
play any role in it and uh it didn't do
anything to move the whole overarching
theme of the series forward it was a
good people like like that one the best
but if if you want to know more about
the whole Specter angle there's none of
that in it
because that guy wasn't with Specter he
was just a rogue agent yeah
maybe he was with specter
because uh Mr White knew knew knew about
him
I'd have to go back there and look at it
again he might have been working for a
specter a little bit but it just didn't
really tell you much about it well
that's the thing about having something
like Specter because
it's just kind of like a loose
conglomeration of
organized crime yeah so it's just kind
of like everybody could kind of have
ties to it and you could do different
stories so it doesn't have to be real
but you would think with
as much money as the James Bond movies
cost and as much money as they usually
bring in you would think that they would
like plan that [__] because they know
they're gonna put one out every year or
two years or whatever it is so you would
think that they would have like at least
a rough structure of
I mean especially in this day and age
when everybody is like super nitpicky
and it's just kind of like well look at
Disney they didn't plan out Star Wars of
all things the [__] dumbasses would
just did it as they went well yeah but
I'm just saying that you can't really
get away with that the way you used to
be able to I kind of feel like back in
the old days like you know they'd make a
movie and then like was like we just
made a movie and we didn't know it was
going to be and then they're like oh we
want a sequel because that one made more
money than they expected they're like
okay well we didn't really think of a
sequel let's just pull this out of our
ass and then they just make like some
[__] that negates everything from
the first movie and people are like
whatever that like they didn't really
care but like I kind of feel like
nowadays people would get like all up in
arms about it's like hey that's not what
happened in the first movie What the
[__] you know what I mean because
everybody's very like into like
continuity and like storytelling and
stuff like that so
uh Zach says Skyfall is what got me into
filmmaking originally because that's
where I learned who Roger deakins was
yeah Roger deakin's very very famous
cinematographer
he shot all the did he shoot like pretty
much all the um recent James Bond movies
and a [__] ton of other ones as well
he's done a [__] ton of other movies
the only the only thing I can knock
um the new James Bond the Daniel Craig
James Bonds for is that they didn't all
have epic theme songs about half of them
did but the other half I don't think
that they didn't sound like a James Bond
theme song to me I guess they just
wanted to differentiate themselves from
the rest of the
movies but
I thought that Chris Cornell went with
[__] you know my name I thought that
was [__] awesome yeah that's a good
song yeah the um
uh the one with the white stripes and
Alicia Keys I thought that was great
that was from quantum
Skyfall was okay I like that one I liked
that song actually it was okay
the Specter song I didn't like it that
much and I don't even remember the one
from uh no time to die
didn't make an impression
which one was I don't remember the
Specter song
there's one where it just has a guy
singing in falsetto it's almost acapella
through though it's just oh is that the
one that was what's that fucker's name
Sam something
that's real high-pitched male yeah yeah
yeah yeah like yeah I know I've heard
some of that dude's other songs in there
yeah I just it didn't have that Epic
like I remember it being a good song but
yeah it didn't stick with me the way
that no the Chris Cornell one or even
the Skyfall song I still remember that
one yeah the one of the best ones Sam
Smith that's his name yeah thank you
Zach one of the best one of the best
theme songs was uh uh the one um Shirley
Manson The World is Not Enough I love
that [__] theme song I always forget
about that movie yeah world's not that
was a good one was that Timothy Dalton
or was that Pierce Brosnan Pierce
Brosnan okay
um
then I actually liked the one that
Madonna did
even though that movie wasn't that good
she had a James Bond thing yeah she did
um she did a chance bomb thing
where he played where he's where bond
gets it gets uh starts off he's captured
by the North Koreans and they're they're
[__] tortured him
and then the movie kind of begins with a
prisoner exchange they exchange him for
somebody else to get bogged back and
he's [__] skinny as [__]
I don't know I didn't remember that uh I
didn't remember that he was that skinny
in real life but he looked like he
weighed like 140 pounds Die Another Day
Die Another Day that's Elizabeth Jack
thank you yeah Die Another Day I like
that one I don't even did I see that
movie yeah I'm sure I probably saw it
but I don't remember it it was
considered the worst of the Pierce
Brosnan ones how many did he do four I
think I have them all
Timothy Dalton only did two right two
yeah okay
see I can't remember and only one of
them was good
the the second Timothy Dalton was
mediocre well me it wasn't his fault me
and you watched one of the Timothy dolls
like I think maybe a year or two ago
yeah they saw the first one
yeah yeah
it's where he um
was set to kill that
in the very beginning to kill that
Russian assassin girl who was playing
the cello
and it turned out that
when she was on going there to take the
shot on that guy they gave her blanks
she was just a patsy not ringing a bell
and he didn't kill her because he
realized that that wasn't that she she
didn't have any she wasn't firing a live
ammunition
and it turned out she was just a yeah
she was just a
musician student that they kind of like
forced her into doing it
that's nice
[__]
she's trying to save her dad or
something
John Smith said that's not what happened
in the first movie he didn't get out of
the cock-a-duty car
right yeah that's that's exactly right
um yeah Zach says Radiohead did a song
for Specter and it's so good but they
rejected it because it was too sad
I mean well you know they should have
known Radiohead they they make sad stuff
but that's yeah I I feel like I probably
heard that
but you know Elizabeth Jack said I like
the Adele song yeah and Camp guy said uh
the Chris Cornell song for Casino Royale
rocked yeah that was that was a really
really good song yeah that was a really
good time
I request that on the damn jukebox at
the biker bar every now and then that
one then the Elysian King song
yeah I'll put them on her which one was
the Alicia Keys one
I'm trying to remember the name of it
another way to die
okay
because sometimes they kind of throw me
off because sometimes
the name of the theme song is the same
as the name of the movie but then
sometimes it's not
and that always kind of like confuses me
I mean I still think that one of my
favorite James Bond themes is still View
to a Kill because that's Doreen Duran
yeah that was good and that's a really
good song just on its own it's a really
it was a terrible James Bond movie
though yeah it wasn't great the movie
wasn't good but the song's pretty
awesome we had a cool cast though it had
[__] Christopher Walken and
um it had uh
oh [__] it was the chick that played the
dab Vamp Grace Jones Grace Jones
Grace Jones was in it
what's up poop what are you doing Pokey
she's trying to climb up on the chair
it was funny about what was funny about
that one is that the Christopher Walken
was playing an oligarch named zorin and
he was making computer chips but it's
obvious whoever wrote the script it
weren't they weren't really sure what a
computer does
they were using computer chips to
dispense drugs into racing horses
through remote control you don't need a
computer chip for that you could do that
yeah that they're just like oh you just
do that with the radio why why do we
need that
whoever whoever wrote that they weren't
quite sure what a computer did some
super villains their plans are just way
too convoluted
it's like no one would do that
yes the little the little uh the capsule
that [__] it releases the steroids
into the racehorse is is is activated by
a computer chip oh wow you know not a
solenoid you know just it just [__] like
that you know I mean just because you
can do something doesn't mean that you
should yeah they didn't know what a
computer chip was
well I kind of feel like that was pretty
it's funny now like looking back and
watching a lot of these movies that were
made like particularly like in the early
to mid 80s when most people didn't have
computers at home yeah and people
weren't real clear on what exactly
computers could do or what they were
good for or something like that so like
some of the crazy [__] they came up with
in movies you had dudes [__]
summoning Satan with with apple 2E
computers right
[Laughter]
you're a military academy be infested
with debt with the devil I mean I can't
count the number of times my Apple TV
stop in the day yeah well I mean what is
that 256k something like that something
like that [__] it's like what a watch
has now
it's kind of like I mean
what a um that was evil speak right evil
speak yeah yeah
if you haven't seen evil speak
it's got isn't that's Clint Howard isn't
that Ron Howard's brother yeah that's a
classic movie that's a great movie
it is fun great movie it's a ridiculous
premise it's [__] ridiculous but I
think that's kind of one of the things
that makes it really entertaining
John Smith said Weird Science the
ultimate 80s computer movie that's right
that's right they had the computer they
they use the computer partially and
partially kind of black magic too like
to make um Kelly LeBrock because
remember they hooked the Barbie doll up
to the computer like and weren't there
yeah and they like Dana made it grow
yeah
they had teddies and everything it came
out in the [__] Kelly LeBrock yeah
would be really [__] funny as [__]
Seagal was there
[Laughter]
she appears and her husband [__]
Steven Seagal's right with her can you
believe
it's like all like scored
Kelly LeBrock even for a brief time
period I find that hard to believe
maybe he hypnotized her she breast
massage
like
[Laughter]
that's a wrap man that was a wrap
he was uh for breast cancer yeah that
was what he was claiming evidently he
had free he had free
um consultations
if you needed your breasts checked he
could do it he had he was he was good at
it according to him of course of course
yeah
I'm really good at it yeah yeah I find
lumps he would tell anyone who would
listen yep
[Laughter]
do is a trip man
but he talked his way into that talked
his way into Kelly LeBrock she probably
thought he was going to be a big star
and then after a while she's like oh my
God this dude's a loser
all the Hollywood turned against him I
think I'd rather like hang out in the
shower with the two dudes from weird
side yeah
although they do some Weird Science so
what's his name um Anthony Michael Hall
Anthony Michael Hall grew up to be a
[__] hunk
I still remember seeing the first time I
saw him all honked out was in uh Edward
Scissorhands yeah and I hadn't seen him
in a few years because obviously he was
in a lot of those
um you know 80s like the John Hughes
movies yeah and he was like you know
it's a little Pencil Neck Geek or
whatever he always played that part and
then like you know in 1999 when the [__]
did Edward Scissorhands come out in 1990
1990 1991 yeah and like I saw that and I
was like holy [__] [__] that's
Anthony Michael Hall he's like
unrecognizable yeah I guess he didn't
want to be stereotyped like that didn't
want didn't want to be Typecast by that
skinny little character yeah he went on
cycle man that dude got [__] big
and he had a great television program
called The Dead Zone where I have it on
on yeah we recommend it because I feel
like a lot of people didn't watch it
yeah it's good like it's kind of loosely
based on you know obviously the Stephen
King novel and the Christopher Walken
you know uh movie from the 80s the David
Cronenberg one but it kind of went he
had like different Adventures you know
like with his psychic powers and stuff
yeah and it was actually like way better
than I was expecting it was like really
really good yeah my favorite episode
where he was working for the uh CIA and
uh they had him they had him doing
remote viewing and trying to predict
where um terrorists would be remember
that in Iraq
and he I can't remember exactly how it
went down they hit the wrong target or
something and he had to stop that he was
going through space time wasn't he yeah
slightly I mean it's been a while since
I've seen in the future where where
things were it was pretty good but
there's there's like several seasons of
it I got it on a DVD
and it was cheap used the whole series I
think it was what three seasons maybe I
think it was three seasons yeah and they
all started to blur after a while we
watched him in a big old long Marathon
we'd have to [__] go back and watch
him little by little yeah because it's
been a few years since we watched him
actually but I like to sell at the old
house I did too I like that show he did
it he did a great job on it
yeah he made a great uh Johnny Smith
yeah the other one I wanna I wanna see
again is uh dark I think it was called
Dark Angel
yeah I've never seen that but you keep
talking about yeah that was a good one
it had Jessica Alba she played like a
genetically engineered
super soldier kind of thing she's and
she would uh
um rode a motorcycle and was she was
kind of like a superhero and that was
the uh James Cameron did it it's a TV
excuse me by James Cameron it was good I
just wanted to see the whole thing I
didn't just get to see it all they just
want a hundred dollars a season for the
[__] on CD on DVD is it like super rare
I think it kind of is yeah I guess
that's fine Dark Angel let's go
Sebastian Moran says microchips can be
put into masks and turn people's heads
into snakes and bugs yeah
I can shoot a magic Rock from Stonehenge
and you'll turn into crickets
sure crickets and snakes
which when you put it like that I'm just
like how the [__] did somebody think of
that like they were just thinking they
were just sitting around like doing blow
or smoking dope or something and yeah
all right you guys I have an idea
what if there's a rock from Stonehenge
and you put it in people's heads and it
makes bugs come out yeah and everybody's
like oh why didn't we think of that
that's a good movie though but that's a
crazy it's a crazy yeah I like that
movie concept
I'm glad that it kind of got some
appreciation afterwards because I know
that everybody was pissed off about it
when it first came out so I had never
seen Halloween the first Halloween movie
I had seen was three so I wasn't I
didn't I didn't have any unrealistic
expectations I didn't know anything
about Michael Myers or anything and I
saw that [__] that just I [__] loved
it you know
I mean it's an original uh concept You
Gotta Give it that yeah it was kind of
like a Cronenberg flick a little bit at
the time you know I was comparing it to
the Cronenberg movies that I'd seen like
video drone and um uh The Brood you know
I thought it was like because they were
planted on HBO around that time all of
them yeah and it was just kind of
reminded me of that another weird
[__] movie and the hand you know with
Michael Caine
and um kind of a disturbing movie you
know they're turning little kid putting
little putting families in test rooms
and putting masks on the kids in front
of the parents and then they played the
signal and the kids heads [__]
turn into damn snakes and crickets and
what else did they have in there
centipedes roaches roaches came out
and then the snakes came out and killed
the parrots
when I was like 12 or 13 when this
shit's going down
[Laughter]
they know something I don't you know
that [__] must be real they must know
something I don't or they wouldn't be
making a movie like this you know I used
to think that way sometimes when I was a
kid they're making a movie about this it
must be possible
yeah that's the way I used to think
sometimes that's pretty funny yeah
they're trying to tell us something
because they make movies about all kind
of games yeah
John Smith says Connell Cochrane is an
underappreciated villain he's just doing
it to mess with people yeah I kind of
like that he doesn't really have it's
like I'm he's not trying to necessarily
take over the world or nothing like that
he's just kind of like
hey I'm trying to get back to the old
Celtic Halloween thing and I'm just
gonna like uh turn kids heads into bugs
because why not why not they probably
got that from the Wicker man
probably it does kind of have now that
you mentioned it does have kind of like
a little folk horror element to it yeah
that's what they're talking he's going
back to the old going back to the old
ways to the old ways yeah and the dude
had Androids turns out that all the guys
that's right I forgot about that also he
had Android he was the only human yeah
he had an army of Android employees and
wait I can't remember but was there a
reason for that or just because because
Androids because you could do it because
he could
and they would obey him that's right
yeah
Mr 88 said you could do a lot with evil
speak and spell as an 80s retro horror
film
not gonna lie
um that would probably work they've made
like a horror movie about pretty much
everything else like all kind of [__]
up toys and technology and everything
like that so
I'm surprised they haven't evil speak
was very underrated and I think it's
because it was an indie flick and it
didn't really get I don't think it got a
full release it did end up on I think
HBO or
for a little while you know but it
wasn't on there for long I just remember
I saw it on HBO as a kid that's the
first time I saw it and it played around
the same time as fun house was playing
remember the movie fun I love that I
love fun house I really liked it I
really like fun house yeah
and what tripped me out when I was I
guess I was about 12 or 13 when that one
was gone what tripped me out was the
scene where the Damned monster was
trying to get a hand job by the by the
uh by the fortune teller yeah remember
that she's getting and I was like she's
gonna she's gonna give that dude a
[__]
what the [__] that was blowing my 13
year old mom even monsters get handjobs
holy [__] man
that's blowing my [__] mind
[Laughter]
it's always funny like hearing what blew
your mind out of the kid yeah
he's gonna get a hand job
these are adults
[Laughter]
John Smith said there was a Dutch horror
movie about a killer elevator called the
lift I've seen it actually it wasn't
great I remember it being kind of boring
because I was sitting there thinking
killer elevator I'm gonna watch that but
I was just kind of like yes
elevator needed to kill more people I
feel like well they also have I mean
there's been a you can pretty much say
killer noun and like you know they have
a [__] movie about it wasn't there
that one about the that was called
rubber that was about a killer car tire
I don't know that just kind of like
rolled around and
killed people somehow well I'm not
really sure I think it was kind of like
a parody or something I don't know I
probably should see it she asked me this
is Kelly LeBrock was his team ultimate
teen crush
man I was a horndog by 10 all right
[__] I remember going to the movie
theaters look at it looking at them
oh [__] what was her name
the girl from Sinbad and [__] uh
Earth's core Carolyn Caroline Monroe
yeah I [__] Carolyn Monroe and her
cleavage [__] they interviewed her a
lot on the new um if you have shutter
they have a new um In Search Of Darkness
uh volume three which is like five and a
half hour documentary about 480 horror
movies yeah and uh they she's on there
quite a bit because she was in a lot of
the movies that they talked about you
know what I mean because that once
they've got to part three they're kind
of talking about you know lesser known
movies which I thought was kind of cool
but I'd be like 10 or 11 looking at that
woman just going man
you know
it's just in you you know just it's just
part of your biology I guess
it's not learned behavior you just know
what you like you know
sucking
Mr 88 said trick or treat was a great
film and I say the above as a person
that is particularly not a horror fan
sorry Jenny yeah that's okay I guess but
um trick-or-treat is a great film unless
you're talking about are you talking
about the Anthology like the one with
Sam
or are you talking like the Halloween
Anthology or are you talking about the
80s one about the heavy metal guy
because that one was
fun but also kind of terrible but the
Anthology one is awesome I actually
watch it every Halloween
because it's just it's it's so
Halloweeny and every single story is
good yeah okay the same one yeah that's
what I thought
because there was another one called
trick-or-treat that I keep thinking came
out of 85 or 86 and I think it was about
like a
like a heavy metal band or something
like that I don't know it's been a long
time since I've seen it
um let's see
Sebastian Moran said she's on talking
pictures Friday night too like Caroline
Monroe
oh well
she still uh she held together pretty
well I think does she I mean well didn't
you see her once I was watching the um I
did yeah I was watching the
that documentary like I said on show
what the hell together the best was uh
Cassandra Peterson
yes looks fantastic it's hard to believe
she's in her 70s she looks great
yeah you would never know no also
Barbara Crampton yeah Barbara Crampton
she still has looks super hot so
and I just saw her like a few days ago
and I'm also on her Instagram so she
like posts pictures all the time took
care of herself
but she said she spent money too both
those girls spent money she looks almost
exactly the same like you can tell she's
older but yeah she doesn't really look
that much older
if you spend money on yourself and get
the right surgeries you know women can
hold it together pretty well
but I think you know it's also Health
they're not doing [__] up drugs and
[__] and they're not drinking themselves
into the ground
Dolly Parton held together for a long
long time I haven't seen her in a while
but
I think what she was in her late 60s or
70s last time I saw her and she looked
the same she looked she was cute look
like Dolly big old boobs yeah she hasn't
changed much no to be honest well she's
open about it she's like oh I've had
everything nipped and tucked and pulled
and stretched and you know
you know it's obvious
yeah and that's it's weird because I you
know people are a lot more open about it
nowadays but I kind of feel like for a
long time it's almost like you were
supposed to get it done but you weren't
supposed to like tell anybody no I
totally look like this naturally yeah
everyone's like no you don't know
[Laughter]
so I think well maybe was it Dolly
Parton that was kind of like the first
person well she was the one that was
open about breast implants right and
then Barbara Water Walters did a damn
terrible interview with her and just
tried to just humiliate the woman it's
on YouTube you can see it and she's like
an outclasses Barbara Walters through
the whole thing and you could tell that
Barbara Walters just jealous as hell oh
you know because you're talking about
how Porsche she was like didn't she grow
up in a poor neighborhood that kind of
[__] just like [__]
poor place in the South you know where
you were Barefoot just just it's [__]
evil it's obviously a [__] fight
between a pretty girl and an ugly girl
because Barbara Walters was ugly [__]
him but you know Dolly was cute super
cute
and uh
but you can see that interview on
YouTube still and just look at the
comments and the con the conversation
about what a [__] witch Barbara
Walters was
totally uh totally uncalled for by
today's standards you know
don't people think that you're
ridiculous just asking her [__] like
that be like [__] yeah yeah don't people
think that you're ridiculous
breast implants and all this just and
she's just uh well you could be you know
she's just tried to reason her way
through it you know what I mean it was
obvious that the [__] woman was
jealous as hell of her
I mean dolly was an eight or a nine
[__] Barbara Walters was a three come
on let's be honest
but it's just I mean it just seems like
a strange like if you're gonna interview
somebody it just seems like strange to
come out and I'm gonna like attack them
like that just yeah well watch it that's
what I'm saying watch it she got her on
there to attack her in public for
personal reasons if you ask me
yeah maybe so of course
it just seems like really pointless it's
not like replacing on her with this well
the thing about it is that like look I
can see being you know if you're
interviewing somebody being mean to
somebody that's like an actual [__]
yeah like and you're calling them out on
[__] like yeah you should be mean to
them dolly was a singer but like I said
somebody like dolly that hasn't done it
that is just like delightful and
everybody loves her like why the hell
would you just like come out and like
[__] attack her like that jealous
witch I guess
yeah John Smith said saint Dolly
displays Poise and forgiveness in that
interview yeah yeah she like Captain
classy that's what I mean so it's I mean
that's what you gotta do that's what you
gotta do it was obvious to me I mean
somebody just comes at you like that you
just have to like just be sweet as hell
to them because then that'll just make
them look like a bigger dude yeah it did
it was obvious to me you got basically
an ugly woman who's trying to [__]
belittle a woman who's [__] oh man
seven times as good looking dessert I
mean and it's just and it comes off as
[__] personal attacks from you know
sour grapes you know just it was obvious
I mean
you can drop it in the comment section
if you agree with me but it was obvious
to me what was going on me Barbara look
terrible
yeah
and it's just I don't know I haven't
seen it but I can imagine it made
Barbara look terrible
like I said I just I don't get it I
don't get why do you just attack
somebody like that like women like I
said women
they do that
yes tell us more about what women do
I've seen it I've seen it happen
it'll attack the pretty girl if they
think she's weak and can't do anything
they'll attack you pretty girl
but the thing about it is that
somebody comes at you like that you
basically just have to
we have to like not get mad because like
I said if you don't if you just like
stay nice and classy and everything like
that yeah then it's just it's just gonna
make the other person
kind of turned it into a joke
you know yeah that's all you can do like
I said you can't get mad because then
like it'll make you look bad too she was
like is it true that you come from a
place and you you yourself really have
no education to speak of you know just
[__] like that right and she's like
where I come from maybe we didn't have
formalized education but we weren't dumb
we we you know we knew all about life
that's just how she played it off like
that yeah we had Street Smart so
basically what you did right
I mean
that's the thing hey yeah I grew up in a
trailer park too yeah yeah so she was
Savage dude
I don't think I they would have had to
like probably
um they would have probably had to like
uh
censor me because I had been swearing
all of them
[Laughter]
do you want some of this because I can't
drink anymore yeah yeah I was gonna say
I gotta drive yeah you gotta drive
I don't gotta I gotta watch with that
drink yeah you do
you don't look as fat in those jeans
females yeah exactly well yeah there is
a very just I think it's a particular
type of woman it's not just like all
women because I didn't really know a lot
of women like that but um but there is a
particular type of woman that'll do they
that are good at that kind of like
backhanded compliment or uh you know
like the passive aggressive kind of
stuff where it kind of doesn't sound
mean
on its face but then like when you think
about it in a second it's like really
mean you know sometimes
John Smith said dolly could have just
said [__] you're the one interviewing
me
that's true
mr88 says Tom's correct
that is a distinctly female play it is
I've seen it happen although like I said
I've seen uh dudes do that too so don't
I don't think it's just dudes do the
same thing and to be honest in my
experience
um I think dudes are way bigger [__]
than women
but that could be just it depends it
depends on the guys I mean yeah I'm just
saying generally listen I don't like to
make generalizations because everybody's
different but dudes aren't doing it over
how they look dudes are doing it over
abilities but they do it for it's the
same thing it's just a different
it's slightly different the way they go
about it but it's pretty much the same
thing I think I don't think it's about
looks though no but looks it's about I
can do this and you can't do it I can do
this and you can't it's that kind of
stuff you failed I I succeeded but see
the thing about it is that if women do
it
about how other women look I mean that's
also kind of about abilities like you
can't manage to look good you can't
manage to get your hair done you can't
manage to like do this so it's kind of
like this it's the same kind of thing
the same kind of thing and I think dudes
are absolutely [__] about appearance
as well
I mean I think they are they seem like
to me
I don't know
you seem like very very into appearance
like of other dudes and stuff yeah it
was kind of different though I kind of
judge people by how they're dressed
sometimes you know what I mean like man
why are you out there you know why you
come to the club in those shoes that
kind of [__] you know what I mean
whatever yeah but it's a golf club I do
that too but that's that's more a goth
thing yeah yeah than a man or woman
thing right because you're sitting there
going why are you sitting there like
wearing some shorts like he mows a lot
yeah right and Crocs yeah you weren't
you covered Crocs in that white baseball
cap class your [__] up [__]
dude you know John Smith says British
guys we are more this is my friend Gary
He's a bit of a [__]
uh that I did immediately right I mean I
was kind of expecting it because I had
like you know seen a lot of British
humor and stuff like that like prior to
going there but they are very
um
up front they'll they'll tell you like
uh [__] right to your face they're not
passive aggressive about it they're not
they don't try to be polite or nothing
you know what I mean if they think you
look [__] up they'll come right up to
your face and go you look a bit [__]
up you know what I mean they don't like
put any sugar on it or anything which in
a way is kind of jarring but um was also
kind of refreshing you know what I mean
because they didn't like try to be
polite
I don't know I couldn't decide if I
liked it or not it was just really weird
couldn't do it in the South it was just
really weird
couldn't you couldn't do that in the
South unless you were amongst very
polite Society
down here
if you were totally odd if you went down
to the [__] Oasis in the biker bar go
to you were totally honest with people
you'd get shot well see that's the thing
I think that was one of the things I
kind of liked about it like in the UK
was that at least you kind of knew where
you stood I kind of feel like me and I
don't know this is not I think it's more
like a regional thing in the United
States but I do kind of feel like most
people will try to be polite
even when it's very clear that they hate
you or something like that and in a way
I don't like that because it seems like
disingenuous
you know and and I don't like and it's
like look everybody knows that we all
hate each other like why are we
pretending like why why do we even have
to like pretend that we even like each
other like why can't we just say [__]
out of my face or anything like that so
it's like I don't know I I just I don't
like having to like be polite or like uh
you know kind of participate in [__]
when everybody knows that it's [__]
that's just very exhausting for me you
know what I mean
laughs
Larry Kirch said y'all both looking good
this fine evening
thank you we're gonna be uh going out
afterward that's why that's why I had to
do my makeup real quick when I when I
got home John Smith said the old joke is
in uh if Scotland ever gets Independence
our ambassadors will be like you're a
[__] but that's okay I like [__]
they do I never heard the c word as much
as
I heard over there because over there
they just say it like
I kind of feel like over here it's still
like a pretty bad word you know what I
mean like I say it all the time but
considered a misogynist to say that here
well a lot well a lot of people kind of
like even people that will swear up a
storm still don't really like to use
that word yeah but in the UK and it's in
in Australia and stuff like that they
just say it like like anything you know
what I mean they just call each other
that just a generic it's like what's up
[__] you know what I mean it's like it's
just like kind of funny it's not one we
use not really like I said it's usually
if somebody uses it they're really
really mad at you because they don't
usually use that and even people like I
said even people that swear a lot like
still don't like to use it
I don't mind because
I'm a champion swear I like swearing
you know what I mean I like creative
swearing also
uh let's see
Larry and creature said up north it's
more real
yeah that was I found that in like New
York and stuff like that too like people
were a lot more upfront and like honest
which like I said I kind of like that
better even though it's kind of not nice
to have somebody like say to your face
like oh you suck or you look like [__]
or something like that but then
I don't really like thinking that people
are like blowing smoke up my ass either
you know I like New Yorkers every time I
went there yeah I did as well yeah
they're kind of cranky but I but I'm
kind of cranky so I kind of like related
you know what I mean and I liked that
they were just kind of like No Nonsense
kind of like whatever the [__] you know
what I mean like they didn't have time
for it and I was like yeah I lived in
Boston I need to get behind that I lived
in Boston for about six years and New
York was the New Yorkers are a lot
better than bostonians man bostonians
are [__] tight asses
in general not all of them I had friends
there too but just yeah
said it's kind of hard to just
generalize across a whole like region or
whatever because you know everybody's
different
and it's
bostonians
were like
cold-blooded self-centered it's naughty
um
and uh
depending on some of well okay the thing
is is that the ones I'm talking about
mostly weren't from there
all right the guys that are actually
from there are a lot better or a bit
more like New Yorkers they're tough you
know tougher especially you know
easties the East End North End you know
the Irish guys the Italian Guys
because people go well those are
Americans they're not Irish yeah they
are you go down there those are [__]
irish-american guys
you know [__] Whitey Bulger and all
the guys and the CIA were all that Ira
Weaponry was coming from that
neighborhood right there all the money
those Irish Americans were funding the
IRA
right from Boston
and um
the Italian Guys
they're just like they were like
something out of the movies you know
like some [__] gangster move
they all thought they were there oh
pretend like they were in the mafia or
some [__] like that I don't know I don't
know if they actually were they had good
restaurants though
pretty good restaurants
girls were pissed off at them all the
time
that kind of remind you saying that
reminded me of do you remember I think
it was from like the first season of
Kitchen Nightmares like the American
version yeah and I think the restaurant
was called Peter's yeah and the guy that
owned it was like a wannabe yeah they're
a lot like that and he was just like he
was like a movie character yeah yeah
yeah I think in a lot of ways that he
was kind of trying to like project that
yeah but that was that was kind of
common in Boston yeah but it's like it
was kind I was like oh my God is this
dude for real and in general when I was
there you know the
the young girl super Kyle you know my
peers that I would could date you know
girls in their 20s they were sick to
death of those dudes sick to death of
them well I can imagine yeah
here he goes ah you know they're like
that you know they were real loud and
they would get pretty old yeah they were
just yeah they get pretty old yeah like
immediately yeah I feel like
they probably ended up marrying those
guys though anyway
probably
between their 20s they were sick to
death of death man I kind of feel like I
would just meet a dude like that and
they'd be like they'd start on about
like for five seconds I'd be like yeah
but I gotta go and I gotta go and I
don't have time for this right now yeah
Larry says I live near Manchester in the
UK haha
um lots of good Manchester Post Punk I
agree uh most of the man that whole
Manchester scene in the late 70s early
80s yeah Joy Division you had the Smiths
you had the fall yeah uh just so many
[__] good bands and then like later
on you had kind of the more ravy kind of
stuff like [__] Happy Mondays and
then spiral carpets from there I don't
know I remember kind of liking them
but uh yeah I'm a big fan of like a lot
of the I love Joy Division in the fall
and the Smiths and stuff like that
we just didn't have some other bands
like a certain ratio and
I'm trying to think who else was from
there I almost said Echo and the
bunnyman but they're from Liverpool
uh Larry said [__] love the fall
enjoy Division I do as well and honestly
like um since I got Spotify I've been
listening to I was actually listening to
the birthday party station and they're
Australian obviously but they play a lot
of fall on there and I was like man I
just forgot how [__] good they were
got all these people in the comments I
got all these people in live in the
comments section and only a single
thumbs up go ahead and hit the like
button people oh you're making a sound
making a set laughs
Larry says haha you know a certain ratio
you're a cool gal yeah I don't know a
lot about them but I know a couple of
their songs
I know a couple of their songs
um Sebastian said I'm in Manchester well
Salford to be exact well there you go
that's where well I have to wear the
Smiths from around there because I feel
like they were in front of the Salford
Lads club like for the front of The
Queen Is Dead album or like the inside
gatefold that's a very famous picture of
them that was taken in front of that
place is that still there
because I feel like
people still probably make pilgrimages
to that like take pictures in front of
it
uh Larry said anyone who likes to fall
in Joy Division is cool by me well
that's pretty awesome yeah I still
listen to that [__] all the time
all the time
um but yeah you know you all right okay
you seem like you went quiet yeah I'm
getting sleepy really yeah for some
reason
why are you sleeping what time do you
get up same time you did almost I think
no no no I got up around time you did I
think
but then I went back
he got up at 5am
yeah
that and then I got dead didn't I
I was in I was on the I was in the man
cave sleeping on a day bed
and then I got up and I got in bed
I don't remember I don't remember what
it was I woke up I woke up at quarter to
five
I kept waking up going back to sleep I
got out of bed at eight
oh okay but it was a bunch of broken
sleep you know yeah and I said I drank
some of that and I'm not continuing to
drink if I continue to drink all it'll
energize me and keep me awake if I stop
drinking I could I could get sleepy I
gotta I gotta start moving
you gotta start moving gotta start
moving
Larry says where are y'all going post
show anyways we are going to
Barbarella which uh it's the twice month
I guess they do it twice monthly now
don't they Memento more it's like the
goth industrial night yeah it's down the
warehouse District yeah yeah in Orlando
you never know it's not public you just
gotta know where it is yeah
I mean I do kind of like that they moved
it there it was weird at first but I'm
kind of into it did you go in there and
it just looks like a regular Club
yeah it's very strange yeah I think the
other part of it did they still use it
for sports stuff right I think so yeah
pickleball
or whatever it is it's uh no what's that
other [__] sport I don't know I don't
know anything about sports
I don't know anything about smart very
Larry says he's [__] high as [__]
yeah good okay yeah Marky Smith rap yeah
I couldn't believe that he [__] died
I mean I believe it because Marky Smith
from the fall from the fall
um when did he die
long time ago no well it was a few
couple years ago I remember like I
hadn't heard about it my sister sent me
the um a link from uh from nme I think
like and I was like holy [__] [__] he
wasn't horribly old I think he was only
like in his 60s but
um I think he had like he was a big
drinker
and um I think he was on some other
substances as well but
he was a cool he was a cool [__]
you know
I heard he was kind of a kind of a dick
but but he was really cool uh yeah
fairly recently yeah I think it was a
couple years ago he never stopped doing
speed and booze yeah
he looked kind of bad and it's funny
because
I mean he kept putting music out until
you know he's because what they put out
like [__] two or three albums a year
Jesus Christ they put out like there
were so many and I have a bunch of them
but I couldn't keep up you know and then
after a while like I was just like look
I just oh my God I can't [__] you
know keep buying these but the newer
stuff I still liked like a lot of their
newer stuff but you could tell like
you know when you heard his voice and
stuff like that that it wasn't
but it wasn't the same you know what I
mean he sounded like a lot different
sounded like a lot different
uh lots of fall songs are like that
though stream of Consciousness writing a
lot of speed yeah he was kind of like
I was thinking about this earlier
because
um like I said on my way to work and
home like they played like quite a few
fall songs
and I was just kind of like
he's he always had like the most
interesting they were almost kind of
like weird like beat poetry or like free
verse or something like that like it
always kind of had some kind of meaning
behind it but
it was always just kind of like word
association it was I don't know like
it's kind of hard to explain but I don't
know I feel like a lot of Americans
didn't really get on that wavelength but
I don't know what
I can't remember like the first time I
heard them I think it was probably
I know it was in the 80s sometime it was
probably
when you know when they did the um that
ballet with Michael Clark
um I'm curious orange and I think that
was the first time I heard them and I
was like man that's awesome like I
really really like that and then like I
started like buying all their stuff and
matter of fact the first CD that I ever
bought like because for a long time I
had a cassette player
um you know because I couldn't afford to
get a CD player and then when I finally
got a CD player the first CD I bought
was was them it was um extricate which
came out in 1989 and I still remember
that that was the first I still remember
the first the first vinyl album I bought
was synchronicity by the police and the
first cassette that I bought was the
walk by The Cure
and the first CD that I bought was
extricate by the Fall
isn't that funny that I still remember I
don't remember the first MP3 I
downloaded but all the other physical
media I remember
Larry said yeah he was like a punk
Kerouac yeah yeah that was what he was
like
that was what he was like first album I
bought was Jim Croce's greatest hit
ah I was about seven my dad had that
mom gave me some money she goes here you
can because I was listening to
headphones a lot at the house she goes
you buy an album which album do you want
to sell on Jim Croce because it had
badly yeah yeah
yeah it has Bradley boy Brown in it
that's a good song listen that whole
album
A couple years later I got
I got uh that war of the world's double
album yeah
yeah that was [__] good too
I mean I said prior to that like prior
to buying the police synchronicity was
the first album I actually bought with
my own money like prior to that I feel
like I had been bought albums they were
usually Beetle stuff because that's what
like my dad was really into and I really
liked them as well like when I was a kid
so I would listen to that
on headphones you know what's like
really funny when I was a little kid
when you were talking about headphones
when I was a little kid I would put on
uh like an album on the stereo like it's
usually like Sergeant Pepper because I
was really into Sergeant Pepper when I
was a kid and I would put it on and then
I'd put headphones and then I would sing
along to the music
because I could hear the music but it
didn't occur to me that other people
couldn't hear it and all they could hear
was my stupid ass singing like along to
the socks because I had headphones on
John Smith said the first vinyl album I
bought was Michael Jackson Bad oh well
that was a long time ago I remember them
yeah that was actually a good album yeah
it wasn't actually a good outfit it was
still in my metal [__] goth phase and
[__] but uh I was in Brazil at the time
that that one came out
and they were playing a lot of the songs
on the uh
the
uh radio yeah
somebody gave me a a bootleg tape
somebody recorded it off a [__] vinyl
onto tape remember you could do that
yeah
I would listen to that every now and
then it was good it was real good
and it was also like a little movie that
came out around that time it was like I
think it was called Moonwalker yeah
and it had uh I think you could get I
think I had some some of that was on
tape
Maybe not maybe some of the songs off of
that bad album were on Moon
Walker I don't know I saw that movie I
rented it
I think I saw it too but I don't
remember what context I would because I
don't think I would have rented it in
the day it was in the day Michael
Jackson was kind of innovative
uh
it had a big production
value
you didn't see anything like that you
know I think Steven Spielberg I think
directed that [__] didn't he
oh I don't know about that I know that
he I know that um John Landis directed
Thriller the you know that one but I'm
not sure about later on yeah I think
moon right Moonwalker might have been
I think I mean it wouldn't shock me but
yeah it was huge production so you know
yeah I mean he had like all the money
yeah it kind of behooved you to see it
everybody
well you had yeah it was
things were limited there was no
internet and you would hear half the
songs on the radio anyways and they were
catchy
so you wanted to go for The Full
Experience
and he did kind of give you an
experience you know I didn't know if I
totally understood the experience
well it's interesting because the other
day not today at work but the other day
um the guy was playing because he just
played like today he played like a thing
of Queen and like some other stuff too
but like the other day he was playing
like a block of Michael Jackson and like
I think bad was on there and dirty Diana
and stuff like that and I was just kind
of like those ones I didn't like as much
I still really like the early 80s stuff
like I love Billie Jean and all that
kind of like I like the old like pre
Thriller stuff after a bad came out I
was just I don't know I didn't I wasn't
as into that I wasn't into the hits too
much it was always like the the beer the
B side stuff the stuff they didn't play
on the radio was better it was pretty
good
Mr 88 said I remember watching
thriller's World premiere it was a big
deal yeah that was like everybody
watching well and it's I thought that
was cool because that's actually like a
pretty cool song uh plus Vincent Price
Plus it was like a horror movie which of
course I'm gonna be into that yeah I
think I saw the world premiere too I
probably did as well I feel like
everybody watched that [__] yeah it was
like a little mini movie yeah like I
said John Landis directed that he was
the same guy that did American Werewolf
in London it was impressive for the day
Larry said I know Tom Diggs Venom
virtual high five bro yeah
name lant [__] uh [__] Conrad Lent
he's got to play Chronos
yeah main guy he he was he's a genius he
invented black metal
it's really just kind of real satanic
Motorhead when you really break it down
it sounded a lot like Motorhead with a
bunch of horror movie special effects
and I love that [__] I was a kid
werewolves and vampires and [__]
vampires and the werewolves [__]
fighting demons
vampires start having sex with the
werewolves and making new cross just it
was crazy
watching and applauding it was just like
satanic porn
he was dead
thing is is it was never really fully
released in the United States
you had to get that [__] off of stuff
like Metal Blade records I don't
remember I think it was them they came
up with it the smaller labels were
putting that out and there wasn't any
big releases for Venom
and I don't really think there was an
American tour in the in the times that I
liked that um it was late 70s no no no
it was the early 80s
early to mid 80s
early 80s to late 80s that's when I was
listening to Venom
it was good though that at war with
Satan album came out [__] liked that
one
and they teased at war with Satan at the
end of the black metal album
the end of the black metal album ended
with the first few minutes of the first
song on the upcoming album like a
commercial he was a [__] he could he
was teasing the upcoming album which
that was brilliant you know it's before
the Internet it's like a post-credits
scene so I get a Marvel movie
was doing
I have Welcome to Hell Black Metal
at war with Satan possession
oh [__] what else was the other ones I
had like three or four more of them they
were good
Mr 88 said great music fact no band has
had each member write a number one song
except Queen and each member has written
at least three number ones which is an
amazing accomplishment that is pretty
[__] amazing and honestly today uh we
had a queen block you know uh at work
and I was like man every single one of
their [__] songs is good every single
one is good I mean I always kind of
liked them when I was growing up but
it's like I think I appreciate them more
now that I'm older but because you know
what I mean it's when we when we were
growing up in the 80s I kind of feel
like I was real into well I still am
actually but I was like real into like
you know Punk and New Wave and all that
kind of stuff so a lot of the older
stuff like I liked a lot of the stuff
that my dad was into like I said I was
really into the Beatles and the doors
and all that kind of stuff but um a lot
some of the music I was just kind of
like oh that's like old people it's like
Dad music or whatever
um and I didn't like a lot of the music
that was on the radio in the 80s like a
lot of the kind of mainstream
quote-unquote music like pop music and
stuff and I still don't like some of it
but nowadays I hear some stuff that I
did not like in the 80s and I'm just
kind of like you know what that's that's
a pretty good [__] song you know what
I mean some of it I still don't like I'm
not saying that there's like there was a
lot of shitty pop music in the 80s too
there he's asked me if I ever got into
Saint Vitus I never heard of them I
don't know I've heard of them but I
don't know what they sound like but I
was in into
um
Venom I got that Venom Slayer I got that
first Slayer album it was called show no
mercy that [__] was really good it was
real crudely recorded but I could tell
that that was going to be a great band
and then uh hell awaits came out and
then um
what was it season is in the abyss I
think and South of Heaven and divine
intervention and all those came out the
[__] great band of good California
band had one of the members was from
Chile
um with his name Tom Araya yeah he's
[__] great
and he and they he he technically he had
a shitty voice but he just made it sound
really [__] good cool he could he
could
it was almost kind of like rap but just
the anger and the [__] hatred in the
lyrics and it's [__] great there's
always about something bad like you know
singing songs about [__]
uh Ed Gein you know dead skin mask
that's a [__] good song man
um blood red
was which was about
blood red was about
communism it's either Mao or stalinism
just about the massacre of innocent
people and thousands of people can't be
wrong and enforcing truth through a gun
and man just [__] great [__] you know
um then they would go into
World War II and it was never really
explicit yet
which one of the things I liked about it
it was very artistic
you had to read in between the lines to
see what it was they were talking about
that was a problem if you had a bad
metal band was too explicit with the
lyrics example of a real bad one would
have been like
Anvil and
handful and that was straight up sing
about Mothra and they'll call the
[__] song Mothra and and then it'll
just be like telling you there's a lot
of the movie and then Mothra went down
yeah yeah yeah yeah little girls like
sang and what monster up so it's just
yeah exactly that's the way [__]
and that's what there's no art artistic
I don't want to pick on Anvil they seem
like nice dudes but um but yeah well
that's the thing it's like you want
ideally in your lyrics you kind of want
something a little like kind of poetic
or something something that's obviously
like referring to something or about
something but is also kind of open to
other people like people's subjective
interpretation that's kind of I kind of
feel like that's that's the The Sweet
Spot yeah and then another one I got
into was Merciful Fate I got my hands on
this album called uh Melissa there's
this Black album with this damn skull
with the [__] Flames kind of behind
it it looked like something come up out
of the ground is that a really cool
cover art and I didn't know where
Merciful Fate had come from I didn't
know who the King Diamond was or
anything you know that's what he became
solo and that was just a
I didn't know it was like I think it's
like Norwegian or Swedish or no I think
might be from Norway
or Denmark
and it was part of that Nordic
satanic kind of black metal
and they [__] that dude was a trip
man you know he had his whole character
going and
like he was a sorcerer or something
it was [__] wild I couldn't
understand much of what he was saying
but it was very operatic his accent was
so strong though I really couldn't
understand what he's saying and he had
about five different voices some of them
were real [__] falsetto like he'll
sing female parts to the song like a
female and then he'll sound like a
little cookie monster voices and [__]
doing all this he was very uh creative
that guy
I'm trying to think of another metal
band I was big into at that time
that impressed me
uh I'll think of it later
Larry said I prefer the more crude
production for that kind of metal don't
you takes a lot away from it when it's
produced I mean I I kind of feel like
um music in general
um I guess depending on what it is but I
do generally prefer kind of a more rough
sounding I don't really like that real
slick over produced when we first got
our hands on on the first Slayer album
it was called show no mercy and it
sounded like a garage tape on a record
but it was real intense and it sounded
like at the time fast punk rock with
kind of like a thrash metal
percussion in the back it was [__]
just really good it was a mixture of a
lot of stuff for its time now that's
normal but in those days it was kind of
like
Crossing genres it was like metal and
punk yeah
it's real good and it was coming out of
California which we were kind of
impressed because
at the time that that came out England
was the place where metal came from but
Slayer Metallica came out and they just
kicked iron maid's ass all right that
was kind of the end of Iron Maiden that
was an Iron Maiden fan
but they never quite recovered from what
Metallica did to them
it
Maiden sounded kind of [__]
old-fashioned real quick
it took time about 10 years five years
but eventually
Maiden sounded very dated it sounded
conservative
it's like something your dad would
listen to
compared to the other [__] that was
going on
well that eventually happens to like a
lot of music I was actually thinking
about that the other day like when there
was some like really really old music on
like from the 40s or something and I was
kind of like
I was like probably back when this song
came out like teenagers were listening
to it and it was like their parents were
like oh my God turn off that noise and
it's like nowadays it's like [__] it
sounds like [__] the [__] that was in
running Stampy or something another
thing that changed the game for me was
uh that first uh White Zombie album La
sis La sexer Sisto came out and that
album was just [__] cool really
[__] cool
with black sunshine on it and [__]
I Am Legend
just that that whole album It's a
classic you can listen to that album
today and it still holds up at least it
does for me
um
and I don't know what kind of album that
is I guess it's metal
I don't know metal psychedelic
it might have he might even consider
parts of it rap I don't know
it was just weird it's just a diffusion
of a lot of stuff
now
when Rob Zombie started going solo I
think his stuff went a little too Poppy
if you asked me and it started to sound
a little too mainstream but
that first album from White Zombie was
[__] great
most musicians I feel like not all of
them because some of them kind of retain
their weirdness but I do kind of feel
like you have a cool band and it's like
they have their own thing going on and
stuff like that but then like they get a
little bit of recognition and then
eventually they end up sounding like
everybody else yeah for a while Ministry
was doing really good land of rape and
honey mind is a terrible thing to taste
all that [__] that's looking great
albums
um even their earlier got kind of goth
dark wave kind of sound was good but
even though he's kind of uh I don't
think he's gonna get abandoned that like
he doesn't really like he doesn't do
that anymore but you know they they
still play it at clubs though but I'm
sure he's like pretty pissed off about
that should have changed your name then
should it change the name of the band if
you didn't want like all that associated
yeah Mr 88 said he just listened to the
sexor Sisto this past weekend it is
great
yeah I mean you know Mr 88's giving me
the order of the Slayer albums I don't
really remember the order that they came
out of
I had them though
and I may have purchased them out of
order too so
I remember hella Waits I bought that one
I think it was I think that was the
second one that I bought
and I remember liking it but I haven't
heard that one in a long time seasons in
the abyss silk is still one that's just
real memorable to me I remember all
those songs I think it was my favorite
album for them
and I liked divine intervention too
although South of Heaven was also good
it's hard to say they that period of
their career was excellent I haven't
heard anything new from them though it's
probably still pretty good
John Smith said my Iron Maiden
connection is I once fenced with Bruce
Dickinson when he was giving a
demonstration at my school and I
honestly thought I stood a chance
well did you think you stood a chance
because like you actually did or because
you were like overconfident
Trey said I made it late long day at the
office yeah we're getting ready to check
out anyway yeah we got it yeah because
we gotta go in a minute we gotta go in a
minute I mean I gotta start getting
dressed why don't you go ahead and shut
it down [__] like that I know I feel bad
because Trey just got here but like yeah
yeah we've been on for we got to go to
the club an hour and a half yeah and
we're going out uh Mr 88 said I hate
that Metallica turned out to be douches
yeah Master of Puppets is such a great
album yeah yeah honestly sometimes I
kind of feel like if you really really
like a band it's probably better to just
like not not know anything about like
their their personalities or anything
you know what I mean they're regular
guys and regular guys can be douchebags
especially when you put give them so
much money and so much influence and
they make good albums just leave it at
that that Black Album must think the
last album that I bought from them it
started to go pretty either which I had
the Black Album had Master of Puppets I
had Kill Em All I had Ride the Lightning
uh I'm sorry and and then I I just let
it go they
I liked the Black Album but I could tell
that was gonna this was gonna be a
mainstream band next thing you know
they're playing with Symphonies and [__]
doing huge [__] concerts although I
did like a lot of that classical like
the I liked all that classical like
Metallica it was just next thing you
know ago these [__] gonna end
up being like Sting and [__] eventually
right it's gonna be old ladies listening
to them
[Laughter]
yeah you know I like his booty
yeah yeah you knew that [__] was gonna
happen well like I said I think kind of
feel like that happens now there's
something I like kind of the underground
edge of real excellent bands that aren't
real well known I always was into that
kind of stuff as soon as they started
getting real well known everybody knows
about them the the art starts to suffer
yeah it's not it's not as fun anymore
and it's not and it's not necessarily
just like a hipster thing like oh we
liked him before they were cool
wider audience yeah if when they start
playing to a wider audience and they're
just then they kind of get in a thing
where it's like well we have to please
more people and so if you're trying to
put water down then it starts getting
like not so good anymore yeah it's
better when they're just like making
music because that's what they want to
make yeah they have fans and they're
doing it for their fans right so like
yeah once once they have like record
companies involved in like millions of
dollars then they like there's all this
pressure on them delay this album Can't
Fail sell a bunch of stuff and it's like
so they have to make it sort of the song
has to be commercial where you know what
I mean we're gonna sell Toyotas with
this thing right yeah and then it's not
good yeah that's it happens to everybody
all right I'm checking out all right
okay
no I just have to I was waiting for you
to see you were talking no I'm not yeah
no I'm just I'm a man I'm just gonna
walk away from him
yeah
and men are rude
all right so I'm gonna go uh get dressed
real quick and then we're gonna go out
to the club and uh we will see you guys
on Sunday I promise okay I don't want to
promise because in case something bad
happens but it's um we're gonna do
Blackhawk Down okay on Sunday like
finally because I feel really bad
because Louie sent it to us and we
haven't
had a chance to review it yet so
hopefully we're gonna watch it tomorrow
night and we'll talk about that on
Sunday but have a good uh day tomorrow
you guys and thank you everybody for
dropping by and hanging out with us
we'll see you guys on Sunday evening
good night